il est inclus cet anticonformiste épris
de liberté tente de transmettre ces
valeurs à sa fille qui elle au contraire
rêve de plus de normalité
pour moi la paternité ces deux de faire
pousser des ailes à tes enfants des plus
grandes et des plus solides possibles et
le moment difficile c'est quand les
accents pop et ses deux torches et des
jambes et de les laisser choisir leur
destination
la réalisatrice à qui on doit la série
montant dessus s'est librement inspiré
de sa vie et de celle de son père le
clown poète reynald bouchard pour écrire
son premier long métrage
ça me permit de oui mais donner des mots
d'amour à mon père que j'ai peut-être
pas eu le temps de lui dire avant ce
sont des faits ça m'a permis de
clarifier des choses puis de lui dire
c'est ça tout l'amour que j'avais pour
son métier puis
toute cette magie là que j'ai adoré vis
quand j'étais petit myriam est une
enfant de la balle et je suis un enfant
de la balle est donc quelque chose
quelque part dans l'univers qui nous
relient je suis un travail et me
souviens pas de tous il ya quelqu'un qui
doit influencer à partir du moment où
j'ai lu son scénario mais là encore plus
parce que je voyais exactement au moins
j'avais été quand j'étais petit on parle
d'enfants avec des parents très
flamboyante qui de toute façon toujours
un passage à temps qu'enfin ou un moment
donné on fait on est un petit peu honte
parce qu'ils pensent que je rêvais baume
au coeur de l'histoire
la jeune comédienne jacqueline le me
crève l'écran c'est un film qui peut
toucher pas mal tout le monde donc être
parce que si c'est vraiment mieux la
mélancolie y aurait de la comédie la
joie des fois et il leur a à lait de la
colère des fois y'a mieux de tout
une chose est sûre mon cirque à moi est
un film plein de tendresse et d'humanité
avec tout ce qu'on a vécu dans les
dernières semaines on a vu ces chocs
ratio là on a vu des chocs de génération
de vous des chocs d'hommes femmes et
cherop le quand tu réalises qu'à
l'intérieur même de nos propres familles
avec les gens qu'on aime le plus au
monde on a du mal à accepter la
différence si tu avais le chemin
commence par l'or ici nabi alexandre
charti radio canada montréal
[Musique]